welcome back everybody to another
episode of cpp for school or on question
7 on flow control set 1 on this I'll
have assignments so we're gonna go ahead
and get right into that this follows all
the previous episodes of the series
ok so question 7 any years input by the
user write a program to determine
whether the year is a leap year or not
now I want to be honest here I don't
remember all the qualifying things of a
leap year so let's just do a quick
Google on leap year and see what we see
what kind of information we can find out
there's an algorithm so here's a little
pseudocode of what makes a leap year so
if the year is not divisible by 4 then
it's a common year the year is not
divisible by 100 it's a leap year if the
year is not divisible by 400 then it's
common year otherwise it's a leap year
okay so it's a little weird but let's
just get into it 7 we want an integer
actually and we'll say an integer of a
year just call a plain old year for now
and we'll take a input of that go for it
standard C in here and then we'll say
well we'll just do some quick checking
so if it's not divisible by 4 its common
here if your mod 4 is not equal to 0 so
if you're divided by 4 you get something
other than for something other than 0
left over and it's a common year so
we'll say here is a common year and
looks like we get some more cases check
let's just do I guess we can just type
up the pseudocode pretty much so your
mod 100 am not 100 it was not divisible
by 100 then it's a leap here so the way
you can tell if it's not visible at 0 is
well I guess it's not it means not
evenly divisible by 0 I believe is what
they actually mean there but close
enough so it's not divisible by 100 then
it is a leap year I don't know why it's
racking my brain but it is so if this
turns out to be anything other than 0
then we get that it's a leap here seems
like it would calculate out a lot of
leap years okay well nonetheless let's
go keep going and we'll run some tests
at the end so if it's not divisible by
400 it's a common year
and the final case is is just a leap
year so if we've ran through all those
checks we should know so let's go ahead
and give it a test and maybe we'll find
some leap years and see if we can
calculate those leap years let's go to
our cygwin terminal here and run it and
then we want to enter a year and just
find which is a leap year the next leap
day is in 2020 so 2020 is supposed to be
a leap year
let's check it it is says it is by our
program and let's just do a few other
checks exactly which years early I'm
gonna sign this random site I found on
Google so if it is if the Year can be
evenly divided by a hundred then it's
not a leap year the year is also evenly
divisible by 400 then it is a leap year
okay so we need to combine these two is
what I'm kind of understanding here wait
let me just think about this for a
minute the year can be evenly divided by
100 it's not a leap year unless it is
also evenly divisible by 400 so this
would be actually not a leap year okay I
got this a little messed up
okay so we just need to hand these
together basically the year is also
evenly divisible by 400 so if it's
evenly divisible by 400 and not evenly
divisible by 100 well I guess the not
evenly divisible by 100 is not required
necessarily so it's easel tool evenly
divisible by 100 and 400 at the same
time then it is a leap year otherwise it
is not so we actually need a yet another
checker here let me just see what their
solution is let's see what they got okay
so we entered the year no okay
pretty close mod 400 equals 0 or so
they're getting a bully no this or mod
hundred and then also divisible by 4 and
that's a leap here okay yeah it makes
sense to do it that way that's only a
simple else if so that combines it all
in one very good yeah let's just do that
I don't have the clearest understanding
in the world of leap years other than
yeah I know we have to like extend out a
year of own smile just because of the
subtle movements of planets or something
like that alright so in this case well
we don't need this helps in front
anymore when it starts out like that is
not a leap year okay so if we get our in
a year and well we're gonna we're gonna
skate first and do a quick check your
mod 100 it's not equal to zero right and
your mod 400 or your mod 400 is zero and
also so this has to equal true and this
has to equal true and it's not not equal
equal then I sleep here otherwise it's
not so let's give that a try
morning cancel out of that and redo it
let's try 2020 is a leap here let's try
2019 not only beer let's try 2016 is a
leap year so let's just take a quick
look here and see is there any other
notable leap years
let's try 2012 says it is a leap year so
this feels wrong to me I don't know if
it is but in there you go it's gonna be
something like this is every four years
of leap year guaranteed okay so if it's
divisible okay so basically if it is
evenly divisible by four hundred by a
hundred it has to also be by the four
hundred otherwise
huh that's interesting about Philippe
here all right let's just try your 2000
is a leap year
let's try also 1990 honor is not a leap
year because it's not divisible by the
400 evenly all right well there you go
let's keep going here before we run all
the time
all right in a company an employee is
paid under as under this basic salary is
less than 1500 then HR a equals 10
person's basic salary and da equals 90
or so salary I don't know exactly what
these stand for I don't know what RS is
I'll no HRA is I don't know what da is
if it's salary is equal above 1500 and
HR a equals 500 and da equals 98% of his
basic salary employee salaries input by
the user in write a program to find his
gross salary now I guess I'm gonna have
to do a little guessing here because I
don't know what these acronyms mean but
it looks like we're gonna have to him
put his basic salary and then just do
some calculations to add up everything
and change the percent based on what
this basic salary is so I guess we'll do
some floats then we'll do cheese I don't
even know net gross
da and HRA I want to have a look at the
solution of this because I don't
understand their terminology of these
acronyms which is a constant problem in
computer science by the way good luck
with that basic salary gross salary HRA
da okay I was close so I had net and
gross let's call this basic salary now I
know it's kind of cheating to do this
but do you really have a choice if like
you can't ask questions about what
acronyms mean you don't really you don't
let's just on unclear question in my
opinion maybe there's some people who
get it right away but I read that and
I'm like I don't know what any of that
means that I have no way of knowing what
some random two or three letters are
supposed to mean okay so yeah you enter
the basic salary basically switch on the
size of it okay so that's not too bad
I'm gonna get out of here so I can
actually write it on my own now
it's alright we want the standard C out
enter the salary so we get the basic
salary and then we say if basic salary
greater than or equal to 1500 well
actually it looks like it's a less than
so if it's less than 1500
then HRA is going to equal 10% of the
basic salary so basic salary times point
zero one or point nine point one that'll
be a ten percent now this these numbers
actually floats unless you put that
effort or doubles unless you put that F
at the end and DA is ninety percent of
his basic salary okay da equals smiles
maybe close to this except a ninety
percent here and so ten percent so then
we'll have those and the other case is
obviously the basic salary would be
larger or equal so we don't necessarily
need to do another check we just know
that if it's not less than fifteen
hundred then it's greater because that's
the only other option so we do the same
thing again we just have different
calculations here let's like it this HRA
caps out at just five hundred at this
point and basic salary it's likely to
get a ninety eight percent on this and
then we just add them all together as
the gross salary if I'm not mistaken
here so that's going to equal all these
together the basic salary plus HR a plus
da and then we'll just say that at the
end here you see out aid and we're just
putting them out the gross salary a
little new line at the end here let's
just give this a quick check by running
it
enter the salary I will say 1,400 they
got paid 2,800 okay um let's say 1700
they got paid thirty 866 now I'm just
gonna look at solution more timely make
sure I kind of got the math right yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah it seemed to be
about right very good
well that's gonna do it for this episode
hope you guys saw I learned something
about flow of control and I'll see you
the next one peace out